my job is as a conservator and a her
ologist is actually to preserve all
these things right so these tiny objects
are so delicate these little pieces are
about the size of my pinky this tiny
bird has maybe over 30 pieces in it
alone and this little bird is part of a
singing bird mechanism so when I go in
to work on something like this I'm my
first priority is actually making sure
that the object stays is true to
historic its historic values or its
properties as possible so for example if
there's a thread in this piece that is
stripped I will not put a new modern
thread or a new modern screw in there I
will actually get a screw plate from the
era from which this piece was made and
remake the screw using historically
accurate threads because this was made
before screws were standardized so here
is this tiny little mechanism there's
our little protagonist our singing bird
and each of these pieces are really
different
that one I call panic attack he's very
quick they all have these really
specific personalities so basically each
one though
many of them were produced in a series
and produced by the same firm none of
them were really the same the parts are
not interchangeable so you can't have
one and change things from one to the
other and even the song and the way that
it's feathered and the way that it
behaves is really a reflection of the
craftsman that engineered it and made it
made it by hand this is another one my
favorite
so inside you actually see a video
that's a little bit larger which will
explain it all to you but basically it's
a bellows and a slide whistle with a
plunger that goes in at a depth that's
programmed it's predetermined by a cam
so we were actually pretty obsessed with
reanimating dead things so not only were
using skin on flute fingers but we were
taking real birds that were taxidermied
and then stuffing them with clockwork so
what's interesting about this is that we
have this beautiful scarlet tanager that
is you know still alive long after all
of its family and counterparts have
moved on this is a piece that I actually
did here I made this bird from scratch
it's not a stuffed bird individual
feathers have been applied so there you
can see the bellows there pumping there
on the left and then you have the slide
whistle and you can see there's a
plunger that's moving in and out at a
rapid pace this is all dictated by these
tooths wheels which are called cams and
basically the cams are telling that that
plunger how far to go inside the whistle
bore and then at the same time you have
a release of a valve and that's causing
the trill of the bird so that's where
you're getting the and then you get
there like that this is an interesting
piece that I worked on for the National
Trust this was an angle C in the angle c
a.b National Trust House in the United
Kingdom this actually was from the
Forbidden City Museum there in Beijing
this had been owned by one of the
Emperor's and what's really interesting
about this piece and what's interesting
about all of these pieces and these
examples that I'm showing it was
that each one is quite different and the
ethical considerations that we give to
each piece are quite considered so this
is an interesting example of a fusion
between basically Chinese engineering
and English engineering so we had this
original mechanism being made in London
and it was also made by James Kok so the
gentlemen that created that Stirling
Swan as well as that peacock clock made
this clock now this has two mechanisms
it has a simple clock mechanism that's
used for telling the time and then it
has a more complicated otamatone
mechanism with bells and such for
playing music and governing the movement
of the different figures on this clock
so what happened was when it went to I
went to Beijing when it went to the
Forbidden City the Emperor decided that
it didn't play fast enough he didn't
want the western music so what he had
his clock makers do was to actually
remove the original Springs and put much
larger springs in this made it run much
faster so we ended up having something
that didn't quite sound like it did when
it left here
and probably what's most fascinating
about that particular pieces journey is
the fact that the people at Anglesey
abbey that had visited and seen this
clock play got so used to hearing it and
seeing it play in this modified state
that when it came time to do the
restoration they decided they wanted it
left as it was so the National Trust
decided to leave it in an altered state
which actually long-term was detrimental
for the movement so we had to do some
creative problem-solving with that
[Music]